hamish are nervous I'm here to pick my
all-time chiefs and 49ers lineup my
first pick has got to be my god Tyree
killed right here one of the fastest
players in the league got to go what's
up read the first trick my second pick
was obviously the the great Patrick
Willis one of the great linebackers in
the league Hall of Famer and now that
spent three all right
my third pick I picked Patrick mahomes
because I needed eat a great quarterback
gotta have a quarterback with a good on
I can get it to my receivers like Tyreke
so my fourth one I had to go with I had
to go with Derrick Thomas Bama guy roll
tide
so one of the best pass rushes to do it
man rest in peace torn I'm going oh yeah
we went with Tony Gonzalez for the three
for my last one okay so right here my
first pick was obviously Tyree killed
one of the fastest players I feel like
in the history of the National Football
League just because of this you know
world-class speed hopefully he goes into
the Olympics or whatever he wants to do
with that my second pit was Patrick
Willis obviously I played inside
linebacker one of the great some of the
guys one of the guys that I looked at on
film you know just on how to play that
inside linebacker position my third pit
was patching my home I really needed an
elite quarterback to be able to get the
ball to my receivers and a guy that can
win football games
my poor pick was Derrick Thomas
obviously a roll tide roll tide guy was
one of the best pass verses that come to
Alabama resting teaspoon and last but
not least my fifth guy another Hall of
Famer Tony Gonzalez who put up crazy
numbers probably one of the greatest
ideas to ever play the game so this is
my squad right here I feel like my squad
is the best bit just because of the this
the uniqueness I feel like a lot of
these guys mindset wise they just date
they know how to win and they know how
to get the job done they play with a
mentality of that they don't care who it
it they're gonna they gonna kick butt so
I would say this is a reason why my
squad probably the best right now yeah
once again was fun this is what Sean
Davis I'm signing out and here you go
out built my squad